tails are like opinions basically
everyone has them fish birds most
reptiles and even some of our closest
relatives so why are we missing out
since tails first evolved at least 500
million years ago they've taken on every
role imaginable geckos use them to store
fat birds use them to steer through the
air and rattlesnakes use them to scare
off predators but for most mammals they
serve one major purpose balance yet as
you get closer to humans on the
evolutionary tree tails disappear
gorillas don't have them and neither do
chimps or any other eight including us
of course to understand why take a look
at how we walk some of us primates
Crouch with our chests how diagonally to
the ground
others like Gibbons and humans can walk
completely upright now walking like this
gives us a huge advantage because unlike
four-legged animals which have to pour
energy into every step they take two
legs take advantage of gravity which
does some of the work for us
you see each time we take a step gravity
pulls us forward the end result is that
when we walk we use around 25% less
energy than walking in all fours and in
the wild every ounce of energy you save
can mean the difference between survival
and starvation but this way of getting
around also totally eliminates the need
for a tail because even though a human
head will use a hefty five kilograms it
sits on top of the body when you walk
not in front so you don't need a tail as
a counterbalance pretty disappointing
huh that being said you can still see a
reminder of a time when our ancient
primate ancestors had one just look at a
Hume
spying you can see how the last few
bones are partially fused together
that's your tailbone it's all that's
left of our tail
and yes it's sad and pathetic and you
can't wag it now in rare cases babies
are born with what looks like a tail but
that's not what's really going on most
often these tails are actually tumors
cysts or even a parasitic twin even more
occasionally they're a true outgrowth of
the spine but are completely boneless a
soft tube made entirely of fat and
tissue these types of tails usually form
as a birth defect a deformity of the
spine called spina bifida and in these
situations
doctors will surgically remove the tails
with no harm to the baby
but as cool as it might sound to have an
extra limb to swing through the trees or
keep mosquitoes away we are who we are
today because well we don't